goal for the rest of today is to get the
uh two new sample
environments commented, cleaned up,
documented, and also to put a tutorial
on our homepage for
that. Do that and then we're probably
going to see if we can get some sweeps
going on uh some of the more complicated
MS, try to stress test some things, try
to fix some user issues like some user
submitted bugs, just variety of
different things.
So, so speaking of which, Captain had
some uh some issues. So, let's see if
he's
We'll see if he's uh he's here. And in
the meantime, we
will that over
there and uh keep on this little
refactor.
Okay, that gets rid of this function and
this function. Done.
and that's 228
lines including
comments. Let's see if there's anything
in here that seems redundant.
Got our
strus. Client has a strct.
fine. Have the extra client strct like
that.
I am a little bit knowledge impaired
real RL learner. Could you explain if
not taking too much time what is the
exact issue that puffer lib is
targeting? My exam understanding the
direct goal is to sit between the
environments and learning how them to
deal with vectorization. Therefore am I
misinformed? So that is what we started
off doing in puffer. So like in the
first few months of dev that was the
original goal was that multipprocessing
as it is typically used is very janky.
It only supports certain types of m
doesn't have m native multi- aent
support doesn't support complex
observation and action spaces whole
bunch of problems and it's incredibly
slow. So the first thing that puffer did
was fix that. So we have very fast uh
parallel processing. It works with our
own environments. It works with
gymnasium environments. It works with
petting zoo environments. It uses much
much more optimized shared memory and a
whole bunch of other tricks uh
asynchronous simulation, double
buffering, lots of different tricks that
are in the paper uh to make
vectorization up to like 10x
faster. So that was the first thing we
did, but that's like we've had we have
two major releases basically since then.
So now we also have uh 20 ultra high
performance environments written in C
that we use for all our own research
that run at millions of steps per second
and we have a trainer that actually can
train at millions of steps per second.
So I mean if you compare to like the
libraries that we were trying to build
infrastructure to support before like
SP3 and RLIB and all those we just train
a 100 to a thousand times faster now. So
we still provide these compatibility
tools for use with other libraries, but
really at this point you should consider
using our tools because everything is
just so so dramatically faster. We're
also doing our own algorithm research
now. So we have a better PO like PO with
additional things that is just better
across the board.
Um we have benchmarks on all of our
environments. We have we're setting like
soda on other people's environments. Uh
so it's become much much more than what
we started essentially. It's really it's
a comprehensive effort now to just make
reinforcement learning ultra fast, ultra
simple and very very stable and sane.
That's what Puffer
does. And I stream all of the dev
because why not? It's all open source
and we're always looking to get more
people uh interested in contributing
building environments, helping us run
experiments, helping on science side,
all the different things that we do.
trainers departed from torch tracks. No,
they're still implemented in uh our
trainer still in torch. But the thing is
it's just like it's so much more
efficient than what was being done
before. Like there were a half dozen
different places where people were just
losing 99% of their PF in training. Um
to give you an idea, right? Like the
vast majority of training that's done in
reinforcement learning, like you look at
your average lab, a lot of them are
still on singledigit thousand step per
second trainers. Um, some of the better
ones are now in like double digits. And
then the ones with full GPUms sometimes
get triple digit like thousand. So like
100,000 or something, but that's like a
very very few labs with a very few
environments that can even do that. So
our training we run typically between
400,000 and 4 million steps per second
depending on the architecture and the um
the model size. Uh a lot of our simpler
tests that we use for primary research
run like 2 to four million steps per
second training on one
GPU. And our training code is simpler
than the slower libraries that it
replaces. Um it works out of the box
with multi- aent. It works out of the
box with a whole bunch of things that
aren't even supported generally
elsewhere. Uh the environment code is
way simpler. It's way way easier to
build environments in Puffer Lib than it
is in Jax, for instance, or like PyTorch
accelerated GPUms. Way way faster to
build our stuff because you just write
arbitrary code and it's fast. Um yeah,
it's like a really comprehensive effort,
but we're not like we're not giving you
our own trainer API that's like you have
to go learn. It's just PyTorch. It's
very vanilla pietorch. It's just that
our code is way better optimized, right?
Um, we didn't come up with like a crazy
new interface. It's almost identical to
the gymnasium vector interface, just
faster, right? So, we really try to make
stuff just
simple. Working through SMB now. Haven't
finished P1 yet. Notice the proper
vectorization matters a lot in
responsiveness. Yes, it does.
Multi-agent sounds like a nightmare to
Marshall. It's not is the thing. It's
literally the way that we do it.
Multi-agent is no more complicated than
single agent at all.
So, this end that I built
here actually. Can I can I eval this for
you?
Let me see if I can just remember which
of these checkpoints is any good. Okay,
so here's a multi-agent environment
about Puffer Libs eating stars. I built
this just as a tutorial as like a really
simple thing to get people started. This
thing trains 100 million steps in 25
seconds on my local GPU. Um, it worked
instantly with our just our default
training setup and I built this thing
yesterday on stream. So there was no
code for this yesterday and now it just
works.
up? So, yeah, this thing trains four
million steps a second. And like it's a
very simple end, but this is really
really clean as far as like multi- aent
uh multi- aent just like forging type
behavior
goes. Yeah, the evals are on the website
as well. So, you can literally watch
agents playing the games in your
browser.
and they're running locally as
well. I will be honest with you also I
have I've never read this on an embaro
book. I do a lot more engineering side
stuff that really seems to matter a lot.
I do some algorithm stuff to be fair. I
occasionally we have like some algorithm
advancements in puffer that make a big
difference
but so so so much in RL is just getting
the engineering right.
The way I look at it is that there have
been a lot of mathematically very smart
people in RL. Um, that's not why the
field is stuck right now. That's not why
like everything is so difficult. Because
all the code is slow.
Aren't some parts of environments
inherently serial? Such as environments
that get more complicated, they will be
less easily vectorized. Well, here's the
thing. So, we just write stuff in C, but
we don't care if things are serial or
not. It's not running on GPU. Um, our
code runs like a million steps a second.
So, we're not just like running one
environment per core. We're running like
a thousand environments per core. Some
of those are slower than others. It
doesn't matter because it gets amortized
out anyways. And like we literally end
up saturating the GPU with one or two
CPU cores with most of our
environments. So like when you get to a
certain speed threshold, it really
doesn't
matter. More headless environments.
Well, that's one of the things we do,
right? like it's one of the main ways
that we scale out the open- source
contributor side because the easiest way
to get new people into RL is say hey you
know if you want to learn RL come up
with a new environment that you would
think would be interesting build it and
go through the process of building the
environment and getting RL working on it
so that you see the full end to end loop
so that's how we get a lot of these
environments contributed it's from
people that are trying to learn RL and
are like building cool environments I
build a few of them for myself for
various research purposes as well those
are also there and and the library grows
that way. Um, we're also we have our
work that we do on infrastructure and
good training. We have our own
algorithms in this next update. We're
shipping our own uh really high quality
hyperparameter tuning algorithm. We're
shipping our new trainer which has a new
advantage function. It's got a whole
bunch of additional improvements. It's
very fast. It's got very nice logging
integration. So, we really do everything
um in RL. Like this is a comprehensive
effort to like fix all the things that
are wrong with this
field. Port working on Flappy Bird.
Awesome. We would like a Flappy Bird M.
Maybe a Flappy Puffer
M. Maybe load the Puffer
M. I have no idea how nobody has
submitted one of those yet, but um yeah,
go for
it. What do you do for logging? I notice
logging is very underdeveloped in RL
space. So we just have a very nice way
where anything that you have in this log
strct
uh anything that you put in this log
strct there is a very clean way to just
get it integrated with well aggregated
across like a thousand environments at
reasonable intervals and then we just
have backend integrations with WY and
Neptune and it's like 20 lines of code
if you want to add your own of those. So
like when I do my experiments um I'm not
just looking at like one plot, right? If
I go to Neptune
here, I have 30,000
experiments from the last few months and
I can go to any of these tags and like I
can go to this maze tag here. This is a
hyperparameter sweep and I can see all
these graphs that are getting logged
from um from C. Hang on.
So I have all these graphs from C but
then I also have these dashboards which
I can actually see like hyperparameter
sensitivity. So I can see like this is
the stable regime for learning rate.
This is a stable regime for gamuts very
high. I can see like lambda. I have all
sorts of different views. I can see
sweep progress. So I can see like how
the parameters were fit over the course
of a sweep and sensitivity therein. Um I
just have a ton a ton of insights here
and it mostly it just comes from the
speed frankly because like these aren't
necessarily things that people couldn't
do before. The difference is that these
100 experiments or these like 178
experiments this is like I don't know 30
billion steps of training data or
something and uh this ran overnight on
one GPU. So like we just have so so so
much more data and so much uh so much
faster at such smaller scale that we can
just do things that would previously
have been reserved for Google which is
why we've been able to make so much
progress so
quickly. Why do you prefer C? Why you
prefer using C
inside I I assume that means instead of
C++ it's just simpler and easier like I
don't want to deal with the giant C
standard library. I don't want to deal
with people with boost. I don't want to
deal with like all the crazy things with
PE that things do in C++. C is just
really easy. That's
all. I like simple
easy. Like I any of the environments
that I've worked on, I can just give
people the code file for it. Like I can
give a first year undergrad the code for
neural MMO 3 which is arguably one of
the most sophisticated RL environments
out there and like a first year
undergrad who's taken their first
systems course can just read that code
from top to bottom and we'll understand
everything because it's just that easy.
Like why do why do hard thing when
simple things
suffice and runs at one and a half
million steps per second on one CPU
core.
But what I'm currently working on here
is this is the this is a multi- aent
tutorial M. I just built this yesterday
to be like, you know, the sample
project where you can like get a sense
of how a couple different like basic Ms
are written. So, this is like, you know,
I tried to like really just pair it down
to a a very basic end, and it's like
going to be way more commented than uh
the other end files are.
I'm mostly interested in
interrun logging. I was more talk per
run logging in and viz how learned
behaviors interact similar to how ice
plots work for forest.
Um yeah, I mean we kind of just have
standard metrics for that, right? It's
just like you log whatever you want from
the end and then the key for a lot of
our uh interpretability stuff is just
trying to make as many of the M's as
possible human playable uh and having
like a really quick feedback cycle on
evals, right? Like let me just show you
how let me show you how we train an
endbon puffer, right? So puffer
train. Hopefully I haven't broken
it. Okay, puffer train and puffer
target. This literally just runs our
main training script. So it's this is
the same as doing like puffer python-m
pufferlib like pufferl train. It's like
the same thing just a convenience. Okay.
So now here we have this thing training
at
3539 million steps per
second. Okay. And you get all of this
data in real time like this. But also if
you just pass Neptune or 1B, it'll also
log all this stuff online with full
graphs.
Okay. And now after 20 to 30 seconds,
this thing will have trained 100 million
steps, which is typically like an
overnight run for most of RL
researchers. Um, and
then experiments just see what it named
it. And then we just do
eval which runs the exact same script
just know not you doing the training
part and it returns rendering arm load
model
path
8. And this is the model that we just
trained.
And we have like experiments that take
on the order of seconds to minutes for
like a pretty surprising range of
environment complexity. Like things that
you would normally expect to take
multiple days to train, we just do it in
like five minutes.
So you kind of just have a lot more
interpretability in the sense that you
you just get faster feedback loops of
all. You can just go watch your agent
play the game a
bunch. And I don't have it set up in
this end, but for most of them you can
actually like hold shift and you can
take over for the AI. So you can like
try to like shift around the way it
plays.
Um yeah, there's a bunch of stuff you
can do.
Python based and Majoko definitely can't
keep up. Yeah, I mean it's not even
close, right? To be fair, even if you
give us a Python end, we normally still
make it like
between I'd say around like 50 times
faster than you'd normally get in like
SP3. Like we've been handed unoptimized
Python ends and we still get them to run
like 200,000 steps per second training.
But like in our C version, it runs 2
million steps per second,
right? But the thing that's like the
emphasis here is just how easy this is.
Like this isn't hard. This is that env
is 200 lines of C. That's it, including
the
renderer with a very thin binding
layer. Do I need to run overwork equals
true to run 96 Python M?
recommend keeping both workers and batch
sets to
auto. Those are the same as what they
were in 2.0. So link key the way that I
would suggest including the ren well the
render is super look at this it's just
ray this is the whole
renderer ray's awesome also if you want
to do python uh ray has an identical API
for python you can basically write the
exact same code and see in python
um yeah lean key so I wouldn't suggest
doing overwork like that parameter is
off by default because you shouldn't do
that um generally what you do is you
take your cores. All right, you get like
and then you run a number of
environments that's going to be
divisible by your number of cores, not
threads. So like if you have 16 cores,
then you do 96 ms on on 16 cores. So
what is that? Is that like six each? I
believe it'll just end up running six
per core.
Uh, and the way that the auto things
work
is
well, you might have to you might have
to set some of those params manually. I
can help you with that today, though.
Like, if you're stuck on this, I can
like look at your config and I can just
fix it for
you. That's just the easiest
thing. I'll start learning Rayb right
now. Yeah, it's really nice. I like it's
rendering is one of those things where
it's just like you have like pygame and
just these awful libraries. This is so
so much better and it just works
effortlessly and see this is all of it.
It's just got like really basic stuff
like texture loading and low-level
things that you would want and then you
just write loops
easy. So yeah, I mean this is this
environment here is already committed. I
will be pushing these comments up today
and then this is going to be part of a
tutorial on the website for the new
version of pufferlib. Uh so it's going
to be really easy for people to write
and contribute environments uh to puffer
lib learn some RL in the process and
then you know from there once you get
comfortable with all the things if you
don't have a huge amount of RL
background right like this helps you get
comfortable and then you can actually
start helping on our research side right
like there's so many different research
problems that we are interested in first
of all just like new types of
environments that pose interesting
problems for reinforcement learning is a
great way to contribute we have
algorithm side for people that are more
mathematically inclined we've that all
this RL infrastructure and optimization
for people who have like the more
engineering side of things, right?
There's like tons and tons of stuff to
do. It's a comprehensive effort to make
reinforcement learning fast and
sane. Gives me warning saying numm
should be h
uh yeah, link that linky like just paste
that in discord and let me know because
I'll look at that. It's possible I have
the warnings misleading.
and Captain's going to be here to have
uh his stuff fixed in a second as well.
We don't need this. We do not need
this. Make this
end. Do
init
You don't have to join the discord. It's
just it's there if you want it. Looking
to go towards meta RL. If I ever think
of some kinds of M which makes sense,
I'll try to contribute. I'm fully
formalized myself yet so it be another
year.
opinionated current neural architecture
search is quite naive. It definitely is.
The tricky thing that I think is
like the thing that's I think difficult
with the neural architecture search is
like if you want to make this thing
really work, right? You want to make it
fast. And the tough thing is neural
architecture search tends to generate
like really
slow uh really slow models because like
you'd almost have to generate and then
like run optimization on all the kernels
or something weird like fuse kernels or
something. There'd be like a lot of
low-level stuff, I think, to make it
really
good. I think you'd also be surprised at
how quickly you can learn um some of
these things. We've had people come in
with no reinforcement learning
background whatsoever, just like a
software engine background. Um, who
haven't even done a ton of low-level dev
and uh they've been like very very
capable at like helping and doing all
sorts of interesting things around
Puffer within just a few months. We
really really try to make it as low
friction as possible and like you can
just learn things quicker when you have
lower turnaround time for like checking
things that you want to check, right?
running ideas, experiments, and things.
It's just it's a way lower turnaround
time for
idea. Definitely naive for a good
reason. Defining a search space is hard.
It's hard. It's also
like I don't know what what flavor of
neural architecture search you're
interested in, right? Like if you're
talking if you're looking at like old
like neat or hyper neat or like any of
the um like CPPNs or stuff, right? Like
the really small evolved networks that
do really interesting things just
basically via function composition.
They're really cool, but I haven't seen
them scale very well. And they're also
like if you do scale them, it's very
difficult to make them
fast, which is pretty tough. Generally,
I think I like the space of EVO in
general. The thing is like you want to
make everything like nicely shaped
networks that run fast and like run on
big
batches. Yeah, Captain. I'll hop on
Discord. We'll do that right now. I've
been waiting for you.
It's not letting me click the
channel. Hang on. Oh, there it is.
This is like all stuff like Ken Stanley
adjacent
stuff. Yeah, we're always happy to have
contributors. It's pretty much if you're
pushing uh if you're contributing code
to Puffer, you'll see that you get lots
of uh lots of feedback on stuff. All
right, Captain, you got bugs to
fix or I have bugs. Let's see here.
got? No idea. You might I don't
know, man. This Python packaging is
cursed. Okay, I'm working um best I can.
We're going to have the the demo m done
today. That is the goal. And then I will
go from
see. Okay. So, I have n there's ninja
there. It's built.
Okay, using your correct. It's I see
it's using the Python in your PM. So,
it's
good. Ah, okay.
Um, so I see what happened there. Uh,
can
you you run
Boom. So basically what happened there,
it's a good report because that should
be I should have that working so that
it's an automatic fallback to that.
Um, but what basically happened is it
compiled the CPU version of that kernel
for you because you don't have CUDA dev
tools. So that is still a good error
report because it should not fail in
that manner. It should just it should
just be slower basically. It should just
build the CPU back end and just use it
for you.
It's probably well it's it goes in your
container.
Um, it needs to be installed in the
container and it's like CUDA dev
tools
something. It doesn't need to be. It's
not on the host that you need it
though. Are you not in Oh, you're not in
a
container. Yeah. Then you Well, then you
just need CUDA dev tools. Yeah.
Uh well, we use the base container,
right? We use the Nvidia
base, but it's yeah, it's just like food
dev tools or whatever if you look it up.
So I the goal is that this should not
prevent you from running puffer lib.
It'll just prevent you from having the
GPU kernel. So I will I will go add that
fallback um after I fix all the other
stuff
today cuz it actually it correctly
compiled the CPU version. It just didn't
detect that there was no CUDA version
for it. So uh
yeah, that's all.
nvcc. You should you should have the
like you need the you should have a CUDA
compiler if it's correctly set
number. We should get one of those.
Can we get 1800 puff?
right, you take a second to figure that.
I'm going to go take the quick
call back.
So I added a warning for that in the
latest
version. Is it synced? So there should
be there is an explicit check against
total mini batches being
If you're on a fork, you would have had
to fold from upstream or synced
Hey,
quicky. We were live earlier. What
happened? We went for breakfast. I just
uh I just do a quick stream in the
morning because I have breakfast at
10:00. So,
it's some days I run, some days I don't.
So, it's like I'm on for half hour to
two hours depending on the day and then
I'm back for the rest of the
day. Captain, how's it
So run it with serial back
end if it if you see CSX
Yes.
Yes. It also works from
CLI like vec.backend serial will do it
as well.
though. Um well, I'd have to like
postprocess the string otherwise. It's
because it uses
um like it it just like it looks for the
vectorzation thing that matches that
string. Basically, it's a str it's a
string match on the classes in vec.
Yeah.
Uh, you shouldn't do that. So, what's
happening there is that you still have
your mini batch size set to
8192. All right. And the batch size is
BPT Horizon times the number of
ends. There you go. That's
why. So, the good thing is we've
actually made it so you can debug that
now. Um, if you just uh just head uh
setup.py. No, no, no. If you Okay. Yeah,
you can do it that way, too. Yeah, but
there's another command in there you'll
need. So, debug equals one. You can
compile that. Yeah, that's fine. But
then to actually run the thing, you're
going to have to get the command from uh
from the setup.py.
It's just a comment at the top for
now. Okay. So, CUDA visible device.
Yeah. All that stuff. And then you can
just set that to run your
end. I would do it with serial back end
and run train.
So when I do this, I normally get a with
that command, I normally get a stack
trace that goes into the
C. Well, I'm not I don't have anything
set. It's so it's however
setup.py like setup
tools. Yeah. I don't know.
I just have uh the uh the dev container
is just set up with with
clang. I don't know why there could be a
stack trace at the top of all that spam
for all I
So the just thing just pops up is like
an operation not permitted. That's like
some weird permissioning [ __ ] with
my OS has nothing to do with it.
And that only that like that happens
with debugger specifically. Play.
doesn't? Well, then that means whatever
compiler I have is working.
Uh, the Python ecosystem is not known
for being particularly
smart. Yeah, I'm seeing this uh I'm
seeing this linky.
for I'm pretty sure unless we find that
everything's screwed at the last minute.
Like, yeah, I mean,
it's it just makes more sense to go in
the major
versions. There's like version inflation
because of um all the AI companies just
like skipping normal versioning. So,
it's like fine, screw it.
yeah. Well, then every update's just
going to be major
version. Like, oh no, it's a breakage.
It's like, "Shut up. You fix our L."
The thing is nobody actually follows the
versioning and everybody just has it
stuck into their config files without
like a pin to a major version anyways.
So like it just will automatically
upgrade to breaking versions like the
whole system is wrong for
The thing is, Python's really not built
for it though because like the correct
way to do this, right, would be that you
would have isolated like let's say you
have two different dependencies that
both have numpy they would both build
their own versions of numpy like
statically or what however they want to
do it and then you wouldn't get
conflicts but because everything is
global like you can't pin versions
otherwise your pin numpy breaks the
minimum pin version of the other library
because we don't know what static
linking is apparently um and like
everyone has to share the same bloody
version of everything But it's just a
mess. Like literally, this should not be
a problem, right? Literally, versioning
would not be a problem if it's just
like, okay, your library basically takes
all the code. It's like vendored
versions. Everything is linked
reasonably so that you're not sharing
the name space of your depths with other
things that need different versions of
that depths. And you're done.
I mean, go go go generally seems like
fine.
I mean, we can literally do all of this
and
Now, you don't blame Don't blame C for
this. This is Python being dumb as hell.
All
right. Okay. But like if you just run
this sanitizer from the C build, it
works.
So, right.
I don't know, man. I'm working as fast
as I can on it. I kind of don't want to
think about it. I just want to like get
it
done. It's like it's just it
sucks. I hate releases.
It's really close, but it's like if I
think about like even if I think like,
oh, there like, you know, 20 more hours
of like real work to do, it's like I
can't do those 20 hours. It's like I'm
just so
bored. I want to get back to doing real
things, you know?
I haven't ridden one of these like
networks in a while and they're kind of
annoying.
Yeah, this is the
rare the rare watch neural nets in pure
content.
have to make the network a slightly
different way. I think.
I figured it would be good to at least
have the tutorial on like how we do our
um how we do like custom nuts and stuff.
Hey,
man. That's such a pain in the ass
because
like it's I hate when it's like one
stupid heavy tool makes you use another
stupid heavy
tool because it's it's like this is how
you get this is how C turns into React.
All right, we used to be we used to
write real code, let me tell you.
I mean, that's people doing weird
[ __ ] It's pretty damn easy when you
just write loops and conditionals and to
watch your code be a thousandx faster
and shorter than everything written in
the modern
era.
Like, you know, I just I like see just
it's easy, you know?
It's just Easy.
That's where this the debug commands
were supposed
to fix that.
like it's supposed to fix this asand
linking or whatever.
Yeah, it's obnoxious. I mean, this is
why we have it so that it should be it
should be easy. I mean, to be fair, this
is also kind of like why we ship the dev
container. So, it's like there are
million freaking stupid setup things
that can be different. Here's a damn
entire computer that's the same as
mine. Let's use You have access to a
box, don't you? Do it there.
not. If you need if you get stuff the
way you need
it, I can run a thing.
But I don't know. Does that actually It
depends what box you have. I will also
just have the
uh the new containers done pretty soon
What? It's input.
It's state.
correct. Something's just slightly off,
I guess.
Okay,
now get
a overflow of some type.
Oh, wait. Numb
goals. This is it.
These puffers don't seem as smart as the
other puffers.
Why don't I get um
symbols? I don't get like symbols here.
crazy. Actually version made a
difference.
me retrain. I think I am loading this
correctly. I think I just trained a bad
model.
Right. Uh [ __ ] I broke something in the
end in the process of refactoring, I
think.
Oh yeah, I kind of forgot about
that.
Um, that's weird cuz I I can definitely
run with device CPU. So
like Huh.
Don't set
that. Maybe don't set
That's
bizarre. There's so many of these little
like stupid things, man.
I have a feeling I'm going to have to go
through line by line like the old
version and see what I messed up.
things. Like I just fixed one of those
not
initializing Ray Lib before calling load
texture.
again. It's like it's cool, right? I
honestly I think we should do way more
with stuff like this in the future, but
I got to get this update out
first and I probably have to
go recover from all this stuff I've been
doing. Get my head on straight and go
like I don't know, lift some rocks
outside and watch the birds or
whatever. I You think I'm joking? I have
uh I've got stones 70 to I don't know
how much the big one is. It's between
150 and
200. I've got like, you know,
uh I've got an overhead pressing stone.
I've got like a loading
stone. It's just it's fun, you know. I
got all the barbells behind me. Speaking
of which, thanks for reminding me. I got
to do my first set of squats because I'm
I got a screwy knee, so I got to be
careful. So, this is just going to
be that the
cardinal. Going to see if that's the
cardinal I've been looking
for. No, it's
not.
Um, what do I put
Uh, we'll try like
two right back.
fine. This is the funniest thing. So,
there are I put up a bird house and I've
got two bluebirds in the uh the
birdhouse, but every so often some other
bird comes over to like, "Oh, that looks
like a nice box you've got there." And
then there two very angry
bluebirds chase off whatever it
And I have it like maybe 30 feet outside
the window. 25 ft. 30 ft outside the
window. That was very
Ah, I have
I've got uh two 27 inch monitors. That's
it. One's verd on the left and then my
main monitor is in the center. But then
I have I do have to look around this big
freaking
camera. The camera's on a tripod where I
have my desk like two feet off the wall
and the camera tripod has two legs on
the desk and one leg like extended all
the way down to the ground.
And then the camera is actually mounted
upside down like on the front side. It's
a whole
type? Then that seems like that sounds
like it's getting overwritten. Not by
like that's like some random memory
overwrite. Is it before or
after like
um I mean OBS has to be the right size.
There's no check on that, right?
Like all these things have to be the
right
memory. like that's you're overwriting
within your own
strct. So that's actually one of the
things where like where people say, "Oh,
you should use like area allocators."
That's why that's dumb.
It's not the same
um in uh
PyTorch as in
C. Like the model does better in PyTorch
than it does in the C export.
Mhm. Would have to
be pain in the ass
though. I've definitely seen this type
of thing happen before where
like behavior degrades somehow.
does like these guys do go for
stars. They're just not as good.
see. Well, the log is the log field is
just for things that are supposed to be
logged and they should all be floats.
Well, yeah. No, I think so. I that
doesn't seem like a pretty a good way to
scale it anyways. Like if you have a
scripted bot that you want stats for
separately versus a trained bot, that's
one thing. But if they're like all
trained bots, then you should just log
them all. Like you shouldn't have
different stats per drone, I wouldn't
think. Yeah, you can have that.
technically, but then if you really want
to check that for now, just like put
four agents worth of logs and call it a
day. Put four agents worth of log spots
and call it a day for
now.
Yeah. Well, then just have two
till we get your good policy.
There's something screwed up in the net
itself, I believe.
Well, I mean, I can always fix this as
part of
um as part of fixing
I think there's anything else that
uh allocate Ite.
playing.
Oh.
Um, why
does why is platform not defined?
Oh no, it is
never
platform. Trying to fix the debugging
experience for this.
All right, whatever. I think this is
enough for
Careful. I'm going to find a way to
delete setup tools and not include
CMake. And the whole entire project
setup is going to be a random shell
script. I don't know. I tend to build
okay stuff.
Hey Aaron, what's up? We're on stream.
How's it
going? Okay, awesome. I am
fixing our demos.
So, we will have uh very nice
uh M docks. And then I might even send
these to you to see how bad these look
for
you. I don't know. Maybe we'll uh we'll
turn you into a C engineer just just
yet.
I mean, it's not that far off from this
thing that I just built. So, why don't I
just give you this? It's like I'll
finish. You can beta test our doc. So, I
mean, if you can figure this out having
done probably mostly pure Python for the
last decade, um, then it should be
pretty easy.
builds. Yeah. So, this is pretty much
ready to go. Um, here, check this out. I
The one thing is I have to fix our
library, like our neural net library,
because it's there's a gap with torch
because the networks don't look quite as
good in uh like it's loading the
network, but I think there's like some
drift or something. The puffer still get
the stars, just not quite as well as in
uh Python. This doesn't look that
bad. So, this is running in pure C right
now.
These ones are not as uh as snappy as
they so they'll be way snappy when I fix
the uh the torch library.
But yeah, so that's just like drift with
our network. But if I just do for
instance, if I do this, that was running
pure C. Now this is running with
PyTorch.
puffers. Yeah. So, there's just like
some numerical stuff going on with our
uh RC library, but it's pretty cool
because let's say I fix this. Okay. This
is a 60line C demo file and then the the
source code for this environment this
whole with all of the comments included
and it's like nicely commented up is 230
lines and that's literally it. Now the
one thing we use ray as our renderer and
then for that neural net demo
specifically if you want to do that we
have extensions puffernet.h
page. And I've been thinking of
replacing this thing with like the tiny
red C back end, but uh it's also just
kind of cool that we have this thing.
It's like a
single it's a single file like no
dependencies C neural net and French
library. That's really
easy. So that is the target env done.
I'm going to comment up uh the squared
env. I'm going to put them online and
then I can give you docs for that and
you can see how that goes because the
chase thing you can train that at
probably 4 million steps a
solve from the reinforcement learning
conference to actually have
reinforcement learning.
Okay, there will be plenty of it to go
around with a
puffer. Let me see the thing that you
put in
chat like
LP. So the are these two different
graphs and then is
this is this perf this isn't evalf
though this is this is the training
curve okay so
there's so according to the eval which
isn't really quite long enough, but
according to that
eval, it looks like they dip about the
same amount
despite Yeah, they dip about the same
amount.
Okay. Yeah. So, I mean, just put all
this stuff together and we will uh we
will uh you know, send over the final
stuff. I mean, you've basically done
everything that we could have asked for
on this,
right? Yeah. It's like it's like it
turns out that the baseline got
ridiculously good in the meanwhile,
which is kind of what we were trying to
do. Um, but like it's pretty much like
this helps whenever it is
possible. All right, good LP stuff for
puffer and hopefully I think that there
will be there should be a way to get
some version of this into like more
puffer experiments as well. Maybe you'll
be interested doing that side of stuff
when uh you have more like M's that are
easy to work with and interpret and
randomize over and all
that. Oh yeah, you can of course of
course finish everything. Um I here let
me
easier. I mean, this is the code like
this is the type of code that you write
for puffer ms, right? So I have
commented here like which of these
fields are required and most of them
aren't. So it's like this is a required
log structure. You have a couple strrus
which are literally just data classes,
right?
Um here's your
env. And then this is the thing setting
new goals for itself. It's literally
just I mean if you just like replace the
parentheses with like white spacing and
stuff and like
other than the fact that there are
pointers for things that in Python like
everything that is not a primitive is
just passed by reference anyways like
this is basically
Python like because you can write this
in any
language. It really can be. And like
this is the observation function right
here. This is it.
either. All right. And then this is
here's how you reset the end. You just
randomize the
positions. All right. Basic stuff like
clipping is not built into C. So you
just write your own clipping function,
but
whatever. And then here's the step. Here
are the dynamics.
Yep. Little bit of memory management,
right? Little tiny bit of memory
management right here. But um and then
this is the whole renderer. This is the
probably the coolest bit. You can't even
make the renderer this good in
renderer. And this draws the puffers. It
draws the stars. it would be even
shorter except for the fact that I'm
downscaling the textures as
well. Oh, no. I It's not that I'm
downing. It's I'm uh I'm text I have a
uh it's a like texture sheet. So, it's
like a texture
atlas. And that's
everything that
is. And then the only thing you need to
do, it's a little bit
annoying. This is the binding file.
This is what you write to bind your end
to
Python. So until you start doing crazy
things that require you to really get
into like the Python C API and stuff
like I mean this is pretty simple for
just binding your end, right?
yet. I got to tell you, it's so much
cooler now just to be able to like try
out whatever the heck I want and not
have like some big engineering stack I'm
dependent
on. But it's but the thing is it's super
thin, right? So basically like I've got
a 500 line script that replaces the need
for like having some Python thing and it
just uses the Python. It's just like a
small wrapper over the Python C API.
Like it hardly even does
anything. It's really nice that it's C,
not C++.
Um, I mean if we need to, we
can. I mean that but the thing is it's
legitimately it's like whoopde it's not
that
hard and like you know like these M's
you can pretty much the way that these
M's are written you can almost just copy
paste them into CUDA and like you could
just run this to
envel you have to set up like the
parallelism flag but it's basically you
just parallelize across like one you
just do one thread per end copy And
you're
done. Well, I mean, you can paste this
into CUDA, right? Like apparently nobody
else can figure out how to get basic C
to run on a GPU reasonably. Um but look
like this is where is it? Yeah, this is
our extension our CUDA. This is our
whole CUDA extension
file. This is the puffer advantage
function right
here. That's
it. We had
to This gets called on This gets called
on everything every mini batch.
It's actually really obnoxious that we
have to ship kernels because it makes
the whole build stuff like way more
obnoxious. That's the one thing that
really sucks is dealing with setup tools
and like Python compilation garb. Like
that sucks. But like the actual language
itself, like it's it's all easy.
him. Yeah, send
uh and where where were you chatting
with him? Send send us a message because
I was working on that as
well. Okay. Yeah, if it makes sense,
send over. Um, I'd be happy to chat with
him because I mean, I'd be very happy if
somebody just helps with that and does
that.
Um, that's
like doesn't have to go back to the
drawing board. But if he already has
stuff like at least like try at least
use our ends to eval the thing so it
actually make so you make sure it
actually works and it's not like yet
another Atari
overfit. I mean at this point I just
want all the algorithm stuff to just be
like done on that and it's like I'm very
happy to have more people just like
doing things and just providing MS and
tools and things. Honestly, at this
point, like I'm gonna have to spend a
month probably just going through all
the algorithm things, but I kind of
would just like to spend a month instead
just building crazy sims and
uh it's but I think it's makes more
sense to do like split between
algorithms and business side
stuff. Yeah, I uh know the priorities
here at Puffer's got to be the
technically the best. that includes the
algorithms. But then also uh you know
it's it does it is very important to
keep everything growing at a reasonable
uh pace just because it like it opens so
many more opportunities for us to do
stuff. All
right. Yeah, sure. Send us uh cuz like I
because I got to honestly apologize to
those guys. Like I really wanted to do
way more with their lab and then like I
I don't even think the pneumonia is an
excuse like cuz I could have just
started on it afterwards. I don't know.
My whole like mental like my whole like
the whole way I like like framed and
like looked at the work I was doing kind
of just shifted a bit I guess. I don't
know. I don't know. I kind of just like
after that instead of like doing a bunch
of collabs and stuff, it was just like
now I'm going to just like focus up and
like freaking shove RL as much as I can
solo with like the smallest amount of
code plus a few awesome open source
contributors. Okay, cool. So plan for
today is we'll have tutorials done. So
if you want to look at these things, you
will have like a very nice like onepage
doc plus two super short ends probably
like 500 lines of code total that you
can read. Um one basic mult one basic
single agent en one basic multi- aent n.
There will be a demo for the single
agent one with the um native API uh or
with the python version as well. But
like we could probably train your Python
end at 100 or 200,000 steps per second
without even going to C. Um, and then
there's the C to get to like 2
million. All right,
cool. Back to
back. Yep, sounds good. You're getting
good
results. All
right. Oh, yeah. I forgot that I wrote
the terminal renderer for pi
squared. Funny.
So when you do eval um we forcibly set
your be back end to serial because
render gets called on the first end.
So you're not
rendering is it with serial back end.
So the only thing I can think of is the
first end in serial is the it gets
treated as a driver end.
Only thing I can think of is that I've
never seen it. The only thing I can
think of is when we call render, we mess
specifically with the first amp. That's
about it
though.
Yeah, that's weird.
I actually don't even know why we have
it as a list of dictionaries.
All
right. This is
the your Python end commented up.
Yeah, this code's going to get a lot
easier.
I think we're I'm definitely going to
have these tutorials done today unless I
like run out of
steam. That should be at least done.
good. Some of these comments are just
going to be the same.
We have
a we just don't have a computer
observation. That's
stream. Third first time. That's a new
one.
man. Are you here for any of the
technical content and just like trolling
too? Or you just here to troll? I got to
know.
PC
specs. Uh, I mean, this one's got a 4090
and
9950X and 128 gigs DR5.
Uh the one in the back that's on the
shelf way back there has got a 5090 and
the same
otherwise. And then we've got like eight
more that are 4090s with Intel chips
that I don't recommend. And
uh let's see. We're getting two tiny
boxes in like a week or two that are
6490s a piece.
Um and then hopefully we'll be getting
more after that.
Now, can you send me a
PC? No. PCs are for reinforcement
learning. You can get PC access if you
do reinforcement
decent. Got to do reinforcement
learning. I don't know what you mean.
You need to do the
RL. You got 55090s? No, I only have one
5090 at the moment, unfortunately. I
would like many more 5090s, but
unfortunately
tariffs. I want to buy like another 30
of them. 30 or 40.
I think the play might just be to wait
for a little bit more revenue and then
just buy them anyways. We'll see. Tiny
boxes are not here yet. Actually, that
is a good point. Let me go check
on where are my tiny boxes.
Where the heck is uh I put these on
my can't find the
email. Oh yeah, there it
is. So this was on
your
order. You've received your
What programming languages do you know?
All of
them. But I can kind of write code in
any like if you give me like a day, I
can write code in just about
I don't know why you do that for free,
man. You can make good money doing that.
All right, this seems like it's good. We
just got to make sure I didn't break a
ton of
uh George Hotz's like six
GPU
box. Let me do let me finish this and
then there's and then I'll go finish my
my
set. Figure out what else from there.
texture. Unload texture. Close window.
Oh, did I forget to close the window?
here? End of creator must be a list of
callables. Oh, I know what it is
actually.
Why is it on size
squared? Oh, I
know. Oops.
A little bit more work it seems to be
done to get these things to like rain
correctly.
I'm going to go get my set done and then
uh Oops. and kill this bug. And then we
will be back. I will finish cleaning up
all these MS and then we will make the
ducks.
See, Linky, this is the type of these
are the type of improvements we
need. All right, I'll think
of puffing alternatives.
steps. Hang on.
This is 8192
total. Oh, wait. No, this is because
that's
eval. So, it'll do 20
mil in solved in pretty well. Yeah, get
solved in 20 mil. And then just runs
extra
ebells. Yeah. And this is fine that we
have it this way because this is like
our
standard standard
be should really be
8192 on the same two workers would be
Oh, and this does train. Cool. This
totally trains just the same.
So, we can actually just start
um we can start putting these
into uh into tutorials and docs, right?
2 p.m. I've got plenty of time. Let's
commit all this stuff up.
Uh, we should
probably There's one other thing we
right, this is pretty good. So, this is
a
on
whereh pi Okay.
Oh, that does make it substantially
faster. Cool.
We got to at least be fair to our
Python,
right? We can't make the Python like
even worse than it already is. That
would just be
needlessly
silly. Uh what else?
Okay. So, I think that um 113 million
steps per second is pretty good. I don't
know about
you, I think that's pretty good. That
put this in
shape. All right, this is cool.
So we
do
action environ.
All right. So, this one gives
you 35 million SPS. Still
decent. Decent 35 million, you
know. And then you have your pain points
listed
here. I'm going to just put these
into We'll put these into here for
now. I can commit this cleanly.
And this is where I wanted to cach some
credentials. And we can push
Okay, now we have all our nice new
tutorial items and
uh we should be able to just open
up the uh hang
on should be able to just
open buffer tank buffer
AI
file and look at that actually it has
um that's me right there doing like I
have the stream on
a new site. And then what we get to do
is we get to add this to our docs
page. I'm going to put this
here. Uh we are pretty well set up with
the code. So I'm going to do a couple
quick sets so I get some sort of
exercise in
today. and then I will be back in a
couple
minutes and we will um write the
documentation section for these M.
You'll have feedback on what you'd like
to see or uh making it easier for other
folks to write cool ultra high perf sims
for RL, you let me know.
right. I do not like writing
docs and I especially don't like writing
docs for the sake of writing docs.
So I'm just going to try to look at this
and figure out what is the
shortest simplest thing we can give
people so that they will be able to
write M's.
The main thing I want to decide on is
whether I want to actually put the code
here or just link to it.
honestly the stuff I have here is pretty
well thought out.
Um,
I don't think what I even
put in here.
I'm just trying to think how much of the
code I want to inline.
I'm trying to think like what is the
amount of stuff I need to write here to
make this clear without just writing a
whole bunch of like stuff people only
need to read.
It might be better to just inline the
code. Now
I kind of know all the things that I
want. I just noticed I don't know how I
want to structure this at
all. Also don't want to agonize over it
for too long. It's like pretty basic
ultimately, right? Like I have good
commented code for how to do this.
too. It's a lot of code to put like on a
doc page though.
I want to just put no code here and link
to it, but like I something's telling me
that's a dumb
idea. If I just say I'm going to paste
the code and do it like then it's a lot
easier, right?
Yeah, let's paste. Let's see what this
looks like if I um I just like start
pasting this in
Got a a whole bunch of these nice
bluebirds
outside. Very peaceful.
I think I will go for a good walk after
finishing all these docks.
just makes up random stuff. The model
does
I think what I'll do is I'll put this
one online and I'll put I'll leave the
other one on GitHub.
Add this
here. And bugs, man.
Okay. So, let's see what this looks like
so far. If I uh open this
thing. If I open this thing
up. So that Okay, that italics doesn't
help.
Hey Spencer, I'm trying to figure out
what the dock should look like
here. Oh, this was totally fine. Hang
on.
I think that's decent. And I think what
I'll do is I'll put
um I'll put this as like the first M.
I'll give some additional tips with like
debugging and
um I will link the uh the other target
ends.
And then that will be
good. That sounds
good. That's what we will do.
cool. See, the memory obsession though
is a bit weirder than the perf
Okay, let's see what the uh the docks
look like.
So we now
have a
tutorial writing custom environments
that run 1 mil plus steps per
second. We have the square end which is
page and a half of code and then we
have a little explanation. It's farewell
commented. Then we have the C version.
Uh, I messed up a
parenthesy was a paragraph or whatever.
but probably put some like bunch of
things. But this
is I mean this is like a nicely
commented full code example.
progress. Got the M's done. They're
clean. Um, there might still be a better
way I can present it on the site.
I think it'll be easier once I have like
the inlinable demos or
whatever. I could also put a GIF, but
probably just inline a demo.
Um, I should probably just add some
debug tips actually. Let's do that.
Yeah, I know what we're going to do.
We're not a checklist.
I think it does reset, does
it? I honestly
Cool. Um, it is 400
p.m. Happy Thursday as well. There's a
restroom real quick and then I think we
um should probably like go check on and
set up some sweeps instead of just
working on docks all day cuz we got to
check on our experiments and make sure
we're
uh we're making progress towards the
final final experiments on here. So, no
more freaking boring docs for today. I
got the portion of that that I wanted
done, which is we have a
decent environment tutorial, which is
mostly just a bunch of nicely commented
code.
Um, but also, you know, some additional
things on debugging and whatnot.
Yeah, I will be back. Here's the
restroom. Get a couple sets in real
quick and then we will uh yeah, we'll
actually get some uh experiments going.
We'll see how that goes.
right. Experiment's going. Unless
there's
anything. All right. Nothing to deal
with
there. One message.
So, I haven't run any experiments in a
couple of days
actually, but we had mazes working very
nicely. Trying to think what type of
stuff. I think we just want to get meta
going. Let me see if I can get the meta
out to
train. Oh yeah, they changed a whole
bunch of stuff, didn't
they?
Forgot about
that. I really want to get a sweep for
these guys. I'm trying to
think the easiest way I can do that is.
What's their
setup? Setup
have they just do a pie bind
extension. No other
depths. No, they have
requirements
upper. They have
pinned. They have they've got way too
much stuff pinned.
Yeah, you don't need all that, guys.
Let me just see if there's anything
that's like bad
bad. Think
it. Oh yeah, they built it built
something.
This is like this cool like factory grid
based M type
Duck
DB. You got to be kidding me. Duck
DB. The hell is that?
full
key map
him. They have like a new
basic config maybe for me.
yl the most you're going to get is
uh some incline bench sets at the
moment. Move some deprecated features.
Okay.
So
like this it
though. I don't think it's this
one benchmark
sample. It's sampling
removed. All right.
Why does not match number of agents in
map?
Oh, I guess it's because this needs to
be Four.
me. I mean, technically I could just
change. Okay, let's say that I use their
original config, right? Did it
load? Okay, it does. So, I just need to
change the batch sizes
then what did this? So, I have 128
times in 4096 total
agents or is it divisible?
Nope. Uh, so I just have to get
That's actually really
annoying. Uh, I can multiply
8.
Maybe that's not
terrible. So, we do like 30
72 M.
And we have a batch size of 128
m. This Yeah, this
works. Would you mind running that trady
val? Yeah, sure
thing.
Um, where do I get it?
Okay, that
trans.
Boom. Doesn't give us any
stats. At least not so
far. Go get this repo. Oh, there it is.
Okay, it gives us stats. Let me put this
on
Neptune so I can do this in the
background while we uh while I do the
other eval thing.
takes forever to
build. Oh, you know
why? God damn
it. Forget the magic argument that makes
it fast and also not
break. Love when they're magic arguments
that you need to make things not break.
Oh, I didn't train this for enough steps
at all, did
you. I don't know why your eval thing
doesn't
work and you see your errors and stuff
at some point.
that terminal is on. I I mean it doesn't
matter. It's like
semi-privateish, right?
I'm just checking if the curve goes up
on a environment real quick and then
we'll go back to the other environment
to check if the curve goes
up. Pretty much it. Is it score? Score
is the same metric, right?
this? Oh, is it are the prams like
fiddly?
Oh, is it supposed to be perfect six to
70 or what?
This score is 60. Like
know,
460k.
second. I'm going to do a set while I
wait for this [ __ ]
I don't know. Maybe I just magically
improved
puffer. Five minute training for half a
billion steps.
Uh, is the thing supposed to render with
the numbers all over the entire
file? Can you check if you committed
your font file?
Don't
file.
Yeah, just add add your the font file or
whatever. Go add that. Pull
this. I'll give you your eval.
way you do that. I'll
do back to the um at the experiment.
right? One of these
isish. See how this goes if I run it
Not. Oh, Twitter 8 message. Gotcha.
Well, when you get me that file, I will
fix this.
All right. So, let's just go get the
metab box puff box.
do Oh, they have a different
one. Hang on. They have a different
config they want me to use.
See what I can get to work on
this. Heck could I just do
The heck is wrong with this? Oh, we have
the wrong popper installed.
soon.
Holy thunderstorm
Oh, it has started completely
thundering. Hopefully we uh don't get
knocked out on the internet.
Wait, where is this
thing? Oh
jeez. All this stuff.
Then this calls this logger which is
[Music]
Okay.
So, possibly we can make this
Oh, it's really thundering outside.
Well, if I'm off if I go offline, you
know
why. It's really
thundering. Okay, we want
64 64 of these at MMS, I
believe. And 32 of them
per per
batch. And then we will keep this 32k
goes. Okay. So, this is actually
slower, but we will see if it's slower
on the other GPU.
Why not
on this box
Metagrid
requires. Well, we don't like that.
Huh. So, it's literally ignoring the uh
the Rex in here. Weird.
Ah, this is actually pinned. I don't
know how it is that I've been able to
run
it does the speed environment your
policies don't take 99.99% as the
thing like in the majority of RL
researcher environment takes 90% of the
time. The fact that our policies are
taking like are taking most of the time
now is just because we've optimized our
environment so
well. So like that wasn't a thing before
us. Like pretty much everyone else in
the whole rest of RL is spending like a
good chunk of their uh compute if not
the majority of it on the nth
Okay. So this
is
these. Make sure we really give these
guys some good policies and good a good
sweep setup.
right?
416. I did that totally wrong. It's
supposed to be 256*
No.
512.
28. I'll see if this is suddenly
Like we're solving we are solving
problems for people with like single
digit million
Make sure that this
is logging for us.
Okay, there we
go. I will let this
run and uh we will see how this does.
Here's a restroom and get a good set in
and then we will uh we'll get the sweep
set up. We'll do a few other things. Be
good.
Borman. Hey, Plasma.
What's up, man?
Policying bomb pushed up. Let me get
that Spence.
Do you have the rewards
negative? It's never that. I've never at
I've never once had the sign wrong, but
it's funny.
Okay. Make sure I'm on the right
machine. I am on the right
system. I got to figure out a way to
make it just the default be that because
it's ridiculous.
packaging
was. It's all
right. All right. Puffer
[Music]
[ __ ] Font's a little like all over the
place, but
All right. I will send you
this. I can keep running these here if
you
want. I can also help you fix your
uh render
setup. All right. Take a quick look. I
will make sure this this thing is good
in the
meantime. Not this stuff again. Bound at
05.
Yeah.
Okay. Is a
run.
Amazing. We will run a sweep though.
E7 like one
[Music]
E8
I8
auto and we will see how
this
and I'm still on the
wrong uh I'm on the
wrong end. Lovely.
Okay, we will see if this discovers
anything
interesting and we'll keep checking back
in on this every so often. Goes over
here for
now. What do you want me to do with the
uh render? Spencer want me to render
more stuff. What do you
want? I guess in the meantime while I'm
look
at our
mode. I could push the Docker for now,
right?
takes forever even with
UV Docker
build. I just want to upload it so that
I can see how large the
um compressed the compressed file is.
downloads. For some reason, the depths
file has 2K
downloads. Somebody must have it in
their
push. What's the push then? How's the
push
work? Username
tag.
Username
name tag.
Does this not just
work?
Oh,
push. And then there is some uh
shenanigans.
Uh, I don't remember having a freaking
2FA for Docker of all bloody
things. I don't have one, my
guy. Oh, dummy. It's
right, dummy.
There we
go. So, uh we will see how large the
docker
is. Seems large.
If it's like 20 gigs, then I'm going to
have to figure out what the heck is
wrong with it because it should not be
Uh this might be reream
actually. Uh this might be reream
actually.
record. We
record.
Oh, okay.
note to self, don't push Docker images
on stream
again. Um, I'll be back after dinner.
And this is [ __ ]